"God, Scott.
You got to do it."
So I go,
"No, that's degrading."
Then the other voice
in my head goes,
"Yes, that's why it's so hot."
- Welcome
to "This is Not Happening."
I'm your host, Roy Wood Jr.
Now, tonight's episode--it's not
for the faint of heart.
In fact, you might even
want to cover your ears.
[jazz band plays note]
Because tonight...
♪ ♪
♪ It's about to get filthy ♪
♪ Dirty,
maybe just a little purdy ♪
♪ It's about to be freaky ♪
♪ Nasty ♪
♪ Gonna make you want
to touch yourself ♪
♪ I'm talking 'bout smut ♪
♪ Talking 'bout sluts ♪
♪ Talking 'bout putting stuff
in your butts ♪
♪ It's gonna get icky ♪
♪ Tricky ♪
♪ It's about to get
a little sticky ♪
♪ If you think
you can play ball ♪
♪ Stick around,
it's about to go down ♪
♪ Let's talk about filth ♪
♪ Yeah, taking it from behind ♪
♪ Dicks and tits and balls
and clits and assholes ♪
♪ Everywhere ♪
♪ Let me hear you say taint ♪
- Taint!
- ♪ Ah, masturbate ♪
- Masturbate!
- ♪ Snail trail ♪
- Snail trail!
- ♪ Dutch oven! ♪
- Dutch oven!
- ♪ Out comes the shotgun ♪
- Shotgun!
- ♪ Golden shower ♪
- Golden shower!
- ♪ The cha-cha ♪
- The cha-cha!
- ♪ Rusty trombone,
Rusty trombone ♪
♪ Girl on girl
on guy on guy ♪
♪ Just don't get it
in your eye ♪
♪ Here we go, filth! ♪
- Yeah, girl.
[cheers and applause]
Some of y'all might
know this gentleman
from his work on the NBC series
"Hannibal,"
but the real fans know him
from "Kids in the Hall,"
Scott Thompson, everybody!
[cheers and applause]
- People are different,
aren't they?
No, I mean, 'cause for me,
I see this,
and I want to smell it!
Like--
I mean--like--
That's right.
And I'm gay!
I mean--
I mean, that's how much
of a perv I am!
I'm like, "Fuck, I don't even
care if it's lady parts!"
[sputtering]
I just like the good stuff.
[giggles]
Oh, God.
I'm gonna smell it anyway.
[laughter, cheers, and applause]
Maybe I'm a little bi.
Funk is funk, right, people?
Funk is funk!
So, uh...
Just get a little bit
on me for later.
Yeah, little bit
of a doggie bag.
[laughter and applause]
[cheers and applause]
Right?
What kind of a dog would I be
if I didn't leave a little bit
of my scent, eh?
Got to mark the stage!
[laughter]
Anyways, that ain't my story.
I want to talk
about a time in my life
when I was pretty down,
pretty depressed.
Anybody out there
ever been depressed?
[cheers and applause]
Imagine asking that question
in a strip club.
Anybody ever been down?
[laughter]
Everybody just gone out
and sought naked women
you don't know
to make you feel
like life isn't horrible?
That every happen
to anyone out there?
[laughter]
But it was really bad.
Like, it was a really bad time
in my life.
I was really down.
It was that kind
of depression where
when a lightbulb burns out,
you don't change it,
you just abandon the room.
[laughter]
So--and, you know, everybody
has different ways of coping,
you know, with depression.
You know, you got the best ones,
the standard ones--
drugs and alcohol.
That's not my thing.
Oh, I still do them.
Anyways,
I certainly use it to help,
but my thing is...
sex.
I'm a horndog, I am.
I'm a middle-aged man whore.
And I've used sex--
I mean, I'm not proud of it,
but I know if I was straight,
I would definitely
have a hooker habit.
I know that,
definitely a stripper habit.
And so...
what I did was
I was feeling bad about myself.
I wanted to feel good.
And, you know, I know
you're thinking,
"Oh, but you're a gay man!
"Gay men aren't doing
that anymore!
"You're all getting married!
You're all being--"
I can't even say it.
[haltingly]
"Monogamous!"
[laughs]
That's the only way I can get
it out--"Monogamous!"
It seems like a foreign word,
I can say it.
I mean, not all of us, you know,
are out there getting married
and adopting
special-needs children.
Right?
Some of us just aren't
made for office work,
you know what I mean?
You got to have some agents
out there in the field
bringing back the hard data
for the scientists.
[laughter]
So it was one afternoon--
Yes, it gets worse.
It was an afternoon.
I'm an actor.
I've got afternoons off.
And, well, that wasn't
the real reason.
This bathhouse--
Yes, it was a bathhouse,
people.
I know!
I was a bit
of a bathhouse Betty.
That's what they called me.
It was an afternoon, and...
Two for one, the lockers--
two for one.
It's called
an early-bird special.
And so I went out there--
'Cause here's the thing
about sex and me.
I mean, I grew up as a little--
you know, little nerdy fag.
Not good at any sports.
I can say "nerd," you're
allowed to say "nerd," right?
That's not the n-word, is it?
Nerd? Is it? Huh? Huh?
But I wasn't really good
at any sports,
but then when I discovered
fucking,
I discovered
I was really good at it.
So I thought
I need a workout.
So I went down
to my favorite spot,
and what I like
about bathhouses--
so many things
I like about them.
From the lack of a digital
trail, which is lovely,
to the fact that the bathhouses
have the kinds of men
that I like.
The bathhouses have become
sort of a--
hmm, how do I put it?
A closet for the Third World.
Sort of a Muslim closet,
sort of.
And I do a lot of outreach
to the Muslim community.
I mean,
they should be paying me
to help those men adapt.
But this bathhouse had all
my favorite kinds of guys--
balding brown men
with accents and flip-flops.
[laughter]
Hey...
I've seen
more Indian men explode
than a Pakistani peacekeeper
in Kashmir.
[laughter]
Whoo! You fanned yourself
with that one.
Whoo!
That calls for a bit of a rub.
[laughter]
So I went out
for a little bit of outreach
to the Muslim community.
And so I go
to my favorite bathhouse,
and I actually--
it's a strange subculture,
the bathhouse subculture.
I call it a subculture
so it doesn't seem
as perverted and low.
But, you know, there's two kinds
of men at a bathhouse.
There's the wolves, who prowl.
I'm a wolf.
Oh, Jesus. That felt good.
I'm a wolf, I prowl.
The other kind are
the trapdoor spiders.
They lay in wait
in their lairs,
watching with
their compound eyes.
And when a wolf falls
into their lair,
they jump on his dick,
and they ride him until
they've got his life fluid.
That's how it works.
[laughter]
So, anyways, I'm there.
It's, like, the afternoon.
I'm wandering around
like a wolf,
howling occasionally
at the moon.
And I look in this lair,
and I see the oddest
trapdoor spider.
All I can see are his eyes.
He's on his hands
and his knees.
He's dressed completely
in black rubber.
All I can see are his eyes.
Pretty, pretty eyes.
Pretty, dead eyes.
And he has a hose
coming out of his mouth...
Uh-huh.
That's attached to a funnel,
and it's all duct-taped
to his head.
And then he has a sign
around his neck that says,
"The Human Urinal."
I know, I know.
I know what you're thinking.
You admire him, right?
For going for what he wants.
But you question
his fashion sense.
Right?
That's why you went like this.
And I-I totally agree.
I think that he should have
taken a page from Coco Chanel.
Coco Chanel said,
"Before you leave the house,
always remove
one article of clothing."
Right?
Whether it be a bracelet,
a scarf, an IV bag.
[laughter]
I, myself,
would've removed the sign.
I would've let the funnel
speak for itself.
[laughter]
Right?
Just 'cause you're a perv
doesn't mean
you can't be subtle.
So, anyways,
I'm wandering around,
and I keep looking in
at his lair,
and he's still there, hopeful,
on his hands and knees,
waiting for a wolf
with a full bladder
to drop in.
And I keep looking at him,
and I'm kind of going--
And I'm not having a great day.
You know, I've been
wandering around--
I'm there for hours, hours,
and I keep looking at him
and going, "That's--
That's intriguing."
I mean, I'm a gay man, right?
When you're born gay,
you have a head start.
You know what I mean?
I've done everything
that two to eleven men
can do to one another.
[laughter]
Right?
Yeah, and much of it on skates.
So...
that's where I am.
So I don't judge.
Like, I don't judge people
by their sex life.
My God, when I was a kid,
just being a fag
could land you in jail.
So I don't care what weirdness
people are into.
But I keep looking at him,
and going, "God, Scott.
"You got to do it.
You got to!
I mean, your friends will never
forgive you if you don't."
So I keep going,
"No, that's degrading."
Then the other voice
in my head goes,
"Yes, that's why it's so hot."
[laughter]
So I eventually I look in,
and then I've been there,
as I said, for hours,
so, I mean, people...
eventually I have to go, right?
And when you're a man my age
and you have a chance to pee,
you take it.
You take--God, I'm thinking
of bringing the Human Urinal
on a long car ride.
I tell you,
you could definitely
sell him at "Shark Tank."
[laughter]
Yeah, that's what
I should be doing.
So eventually I go,
"Ah, just go for it!"
So I leap into his lair.
And I lope over,
howling occasionally.
And then I, uh...
pull my unit out.
And, uh...
I lay it on the lip
of his fascinator.
[laughter]
And then he waves me away,
grandly,
like Maggie Smith
in "Downton Abbey,"
with these words--
"Sorry, Scott. Not a fan."
Not a fan!
Yeah!
You think you've hit
rock bottom?
No.
No, you haven't hit rock bottom
until your pee isn't good enough
for the Human Urinal.
[applause]
Thank you very much.
[dark electronic music]
Thank you.
- Scott Thompson, everybody!
♪ ♪